new covet cases are also climbing across
asia even in places with high
vaccination rates some countries are now
reinstating restrictions while others
are taking a more relaxed approach
elizabeth palmer reports from seoul
south korea
korea is in the middle of its worst
coveted spike yet omicron may be
spreading but it's delta that's put
these patients most of them elderly in
ulgi medical center we suited up to
visit the covid ward which has been
operating at capacity for weeks
do you know where you caught code
like most people he isn't sure where he
picked up the virus but he has had only
one vaccination which as we all now know
is not enough
one nurse in full ppe works inside the
isolation zone with the patients others
watch round the clock on video monitors
the unprecedented surge in infection has
people spooked even though more than 90
percent of adults in korea are fully
vaccinated masks dr jerome kim is
director of the international vaccine
institute we're seeing now very high
rates of vaccination
not only in east asia but in southeast
asia as well and you know all of these
things bode well in the long term
still long lines form outside public
testing stations everyone always wears a
mask and the government has reimposed
quarantine for travelers
but nothing like china which has taken
the hardest line it's virtually
impossible for foreigners to get in
while the government as it did recently
in inner mongolia sticks to its zero
covid policy which means blitzing every
outbreak with an army of health care
workers who lock down whole
neighborhoods to catch every single case
thailand has taken the opposite approach
its airports even with omicron on the
march are still busy travelers arriving
to bangkok once the world's most visited
city have to be tested and screened
these days
but they are still welcome as they come
with desperately needed tourist dollars
it's becoming clear that booster shots
will be key in managing an omicron
outbreak so asian governments are now
pivoting to that but it's a tall order
with so many people for example here in
south korea only 10 percent of those who
need booster shots have had them
for cbs mornings elizabeth palmer seoul